allora eccoci qui questo qui il secondo
video che giro non perché sono scoppiata
a piangere non perché sia successo
qualcosa di terribile semplicemente
perché il microfono era spento quindi ho
fatto una chiacchiera che è stata più un
flusso di coscienza e che cercano di
replicare perché perché è così che
vorrei parlarvi senza editing senza
stare lì a fare eni pentax senza dover
controllare le mie parole sembra ci
dovesse essere ci dovesse essere un paio
all'interno di questo video sarà
semplicemente dovuto al fatto che mi
sono preso troppo tempo che magari
qualche stronza dalla sparata che ci può
sempre stare
vi chiedo in anticipo scusa per buldo
che nel frattempo russa qui ma volevo
fare questo video anche in compagnia sua
visto che ero con lui quando diciamo è
successo il misfatto ora l'avete letto
dal tar titolo di questo di questo video
mi è stato rubato il telefono
ora io in questo momento mi trovo vicino
termini la casa che abbiamo affittato
tutti quanti insieme e proprio qua
termini è vero non è il ni la migliore
delle zone a roma che sia che sia chiaro
però in questi in questo periodo che
ogni volta che ho portato il cane a
passeggio fuori la sera io non mi sono
mai trovato in difficoltà vi dirò che
l'unica rotto le palle era il mio cane
che come minimo cioè che mangiava
qualsiasi cosa
divora qualsiasi cosa l'unica critica mi
sentivo di dare a a termine allegata
però il fatto che fosse un buffet per
cani di roba hicks che poi il giorno
dopo che cavani non sapere che cosa
avessero mangiato adesso il mio cane
purtroppo sta diventando un po
vecchietto e quindi non riesce a
rispettare il coprifuoco quindi erano le
11 e mezza quando sono uscito linee
supplicava di uscire come in realtà
metto fa tutte le sere perché proprio
una cosa sua e quindi sono sceso
velocemente per fargli fare i bisogni di
quello deva fare
ho girato l'angolo tirarne la mamma mia
quella non mangia quell'altra no afferma
che schiphol da te prego e due ragazzi
si avvicinano uno di queste mi chiede
una una sigaretta io rispondo guardano
non c'era l'altro ne propone qualcosa di
poco poi nella drop non lo so mi è
sembrato che mi proponesse della droga
canino che non grazie mille e l'altro
inizia insistere con una sigaretta una
sigaretta una sigaretta
io mi sono un pochino chiuso con lui nel
senso che anche un tocco di una cabina
riguardano scusami non
non ce le ho perdonami perché avevo
paura che lui pensasse che non gli
avessi dare a priori visto che non
parlava in italiano
quindi mi ci sono chiuso per dirgli ora
non è che sono uno di quelli che ti dice
no non ce l'ho perché in realtà ce l'ha
ma ne sta sul cazzo novero semplicemente
essere gentili confronti non faccio in
tempo a domandarmi che fine abbia fatto
un altro che da dietro mi prende il
telefono e scappa come un furetto adesso
lì per lì lo ammetto ci sono proprio
rimasto lineare da me c'è proprio di
merda di merda perché mi sono un po
sentito tradito nel senso che stanno
cercando di andare incontro a questa
persona per risultare caruccio cioè per
risultare gentile e questa cosa né un po
fregato mentre l'altro mi dicevano no
tranquillo tranquillo tranquillo
poi ho visto che si mette santana
scappato vuole lui e dicevo lì per lì ci
sono un po rimasto così come un tonno
fuori uno spiaggiato
ho avuto un momento nel quale ho pensato
cavolo ora faccio anch'io lo scatto alla
bolt lascio il cane ma un po me lo
prendo subito
ed è uno dei pensieri che non mi ha
fatto dormire la notte
io sono andato a letto alle quattro e
mezza per farvi capire perché c'è stato
questo momento nel quale avrei voluto
inseguirlo ma poi ho ripetuto il fatto
che se avessi lasciato il mio canali e
fossi tornato in non lo avessi trovato
non ci contano ha tolto il sonno questa
cosa ora purtroppo il mio cane non è né
un levriero non è nemmeno uno di quei
cani tipo da calcio e aic di tipo metà
lupo dimostrò mhs è un cane scoreggia
quindi voglio dire questo qui il suo
optional proprio top di gamma e sono
rimasto lì con con lui
sono andato in
in una stazione polizia che era proprio
lì dietro l'angolo purtroppo non c'è
nessun poliziotto in quel momento nei
pressi di termini e ho sporto denuncia
tra parentesi anche con la compagnia di
tutte quante persone che abitano in
questa casa che sono state estremamente
carine non tanto quanto il poliziotto ma
fattore denuncia che è stato ancora più
carino di loro cioè ho fatto 40 minuti
di chiacchiera con questo signore super
super super super genti e chase è uscito
dalla stazione polizia ero quasi
contento cioè
mi sono sentito veramente super protetto
e mi sono sentito che in qualche modo
non compreso non mi sono sentito stupido
perché lì per lì ti senti proprio scemo
ora non so se avesse mai capitata è
capitato un furto che fosse di qualsiasi
tipo non per forza ma materiale e cielo
partite che si sente stupida cela
partite che si vergogna c'è una partita
e che sotto sotto 10 m
magari me lo meritavo
[Musica]
e invece no devo dire che sono stati
estremamente carini ora e lo ribadisco
questa è una cosa che ci tengo a dire
del telefono non me ne fregava
tantissimo cioè è un iphone che per me è
il telefono dei telai fino dei telefoni
sia chiaro era pieno di ricordi perché
in questo mese nel quale purtroppo non
sono riuscito a fare l'upload di tutte
quante le foto per via della grande
connessione internet che abbiamo
all'interno di questa casa che ci segue
sul social viola lo sa molto bene e allo
stesso tempo uno strumento di lavoro
ok devo dire che nonostante questi tre
fattori il telefono era l'ultimo dei
problemi quello che mi ha più
dispiaciuto mi è più ferito tra
virgolette
un pensiero che per un momento ha avuto
e sarebbe un ipocrita se dicessi che non
che non ce l'abbia avuto il pensiero del
abedin allora è proprio vero che non
bisognerebbe essere gentili e proprio
vero bisognerebbe chiude le frontiere
distrugge tutto merda perché perché in
quel momento sicuramente dopo che viene
ferito la rabbia è una roba che un
minimo perché non è che mi sia incazzato
tanto però un minimo esce e il pensiero
stronzo a me che non sono perfetto ogni
intanto esce e la mia rabbia era dovuta
al fatto che io sono uno dei primi
magari non lo faccio sempre nella
maniera migliore sicuramente sbaglio
sicuramente non non sono qui a dirvi
guardate come sono santo guardate come
vado avanti nonostante tutto no stop di
più rosicato ci sono rimasto male e
nonostante io sia uno dei primi a voler
in tutti i modi distruggere sti muri che
volte continuiamo a creare tra i colori
e di una treat mia è quella lì e di un
altro sesso e quello lì a un altro
orientamento è quello è un altro genere
quello lì è un'altra religione
in quel momento il proprio ci sei
rimasto mi hanno detto ma calcio dopo
tutto quello che stiamo cercando di fare
tutti quanti insieme per distruggere si
stereotipi tosti tossici
tumi caschi nello stereotipo nel cliché
del tizio che viene qua a rubare cioè
proprio rosicato in quel momento più per
lui che per me è questa per esempio è
una delle grandi bugie che a volte io
sparo però detto questo capire cosa cosa
intendo ci sono rimasto male per quella
ci sono rimasto male perché una parte di
me per un momento ha pensato che di
forse quello la grande somma che tu
dovresti trarre da questa esperienza è
quella di chiuderti di più di non non
essere per forza gentile
di non dover per forza rispondere che ti
ferma per strada ma a fare come molte
persone non ho via vattene via cioè vado
avanti dritto indipendentemente da
qualsiasi tipo di lo ripeto etnia
religione qualsiasi cosa quindi
ricordiamoci per me un malvivente e la
microcriminalità non appartiene a uno
stato non appartiene un continente
potevi essere di qualsiasi qualsiasi
provenienza e altro credo che sia forse
il modo migliore per giudicare una
persona se sei uno stronzo siano stronzo
ecco indipendente a tutto il contesto e
in quel momento io l'ho pensato in cui
molto pensato per il day proprio
chiuderti nei confronti degli altri
perché non esiste che per essere gentile
e tu poi ci rimanga così male c'è una
parte di me voleva dare questo questo
potere a questi due ragazzi e una parte
di me sicuramente quella sbagliata che
esiste perché sono tante cose che non
mostra in 33 anni io ho cercato e cerco
di migliorare di essere veramente in un
certo senso la versione migliore di me
ma una radice di difetti credo che ce
l'abbiamo tutti tra quelli sicuramente
c'è
non lo so la superbia c'è una
a dosi di permalosità e duecentomila
altre che non vi sto qui ad elencare
perché non vorrei proprio fare un pinot
nero male inizierete a odiarmi per tutte
quante le cose che evito di dimostrare
al mondo
però poi mi son detto dare a due ragazzi
che io non conosco io non posso sapere
sinceramente due persone che circondano
comunque una persona abbastanza ingenuo
in quel momento comunque tranquillo
comunque bonacciona per rubarle il
telefonino non posso sapere da dove
vengono sicuramente ragazzi non vengono
da una realtà positiva cioè c'è anche un
pochino a volte da pensarci su e dire
per arrivare a fare una roba del genere
non posso sapere che cosa ti spinge ma
sicuramente non sono delle cose positive
sicuramente ci della disperazione da
capire che ti fa forse conosci solo
questo non lo so forse la cosa più
facile forse l'unica che ti viene
concessa in in questo momento non mi
sento sinceramente di di dover criticare
per forza aspramente questo questo gesto
perché non so da dove venga questa
questo questo non so dove vengono i
motivi che spingono a fare un gesto così
brutto forse è più giusto dire metterla
giù così perché il gesto comunque è un
atto criminale non dimentichiamoci dare
il potere a due ragazzi di cambiare
completamente ciò in cui credo è
veramente come dare il potere a una
mosca di non farmi mangiare un piatto
buonissimo e sicuramente c'è qualcuno là
fuori che davanti a una mosca butta
tutto quanto e dice di dio che schifo
mammamia narrava facola e non sono io
anzi ancora più giusto non voglio essere
io perché credo che in questi momenti si
possa scegliere e si debba fare una
scelta perché non sempre la nostra
pancia quello che proviamo sono poi le
cose giuste da da seguire quindi non
voglio assolutamente che questo accada
perché credo che una persona che davanti
a una mosca su un piatto smette di
mangiare finirà per morire di fame per
tutto il resto della sua vita perché
niente perfetto l'unica cosa che mi
sento dire se decapitato anche poi una
roba simile mi dispiace spero che tutto
quanto si si risolva nel senso spero di
riuscire a rientrare in possesso di un
telefono il prima possibile e spero di
riuscire a recuperare i ricordi che mi
porterò da quest'esperienza avrei voluto
che questo fosse diverso
lo ammetto siamo alla fine siamo quasi
alla fine avrei voluto che fosse
un'escalation per questo natale un po
diverso ma forse credo che se anche
banalmente il mio video preferito tra
tutti quelli che che è uscito e che
usciranno perché sapete che vi dico
forse ci stava
cioè un blog mas fatto solamente di
risate di casino di momenti di
divertimento anche gli errori per carità
non sarebbe stato nulla se non ci fosse
stato un momento per noi e per poter
parlare di una cosa seria che in questo
caso è capitata avrei potuto usarlo come
un alibi
lo usiamo invece con un espediente per
fare comunque una chiacchiera nella
quale io io credo fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate se sbaglio se sei giusto se
avreste agito in maniera diversa sempre
capitato un qualcosa di simile non lo so
fatemelo sapere perché cercherò il più
possibile di di leggervi mentre nel
frattempo inizieremo a fare i pacchi
perché
diciamo stiamo iniziando e si sente
veramente l'odore della fine di questa
esperienza bellissima stupenda e
continua a essere bella nonostante
questo questo piccolo neo ci vediamo
domani come sempre alle 14 con un'altra
premier del blog io vi mando un bacio
grandissimo e gli auguro tutto il meglio